I am thrilled that the U.S women's
national soccer team lost their match
and are not going to the next big match
I guess it's for the world cup is what
comes next I'm thrilled and I'm thrilled
that the final kick of the career of
Megan rapino
one of the most odiously unpatriotic
anti-American athletes ever to wear an
American Jersey ended with her missing
the kick I'm thrilled about that and I'm
thrilled that she ended her career
whining on camera
yeah I thought we played really well
um I thought we played really well I'm
so happy for us that we went out like
that can you put a pause there please
hold on before we we'll keep going for a
second but this is just such a
liberal
woman thing this is such a liberal white
lady thing where
she says oh I'm so proud of us we did so
well we were so good we're just so we're
the best ever
I'm so proud that we lost I'm so proud
that I totally blew it at the end
why why are you it's okay you don't need
to be beating yourself up over you don't
need to be flagellating yourself but you
lost lady don't be proud of that you
didn't play that well that's the problem
if you played better you would have won
the game and go on I think man
growing up in the 90s I'm watching the
New York Yankees
Paul O'Neill heart and soul of the New
York Yankees in the 90s this has got one
of the great baseball players of his era
Paul O'Neill if he would let's say you
know Fly ball to the Outfield and he
only got
One RBI instead of two RBIs there you
know and he he did and you know the guy
catches the ball whatever Paul O'Neill
would rip the telephone out of the
Dugout wall he would knock over the
Gatorade cooler he'd scream and yell and
throw his Bat on there he just he was so
Furious he took any loss or failure of
performance so personally and this lady
who completely blows it and loses it for
the team I'm so proud we're so great we
deserve 10 parades please give us
trophies and okay all right rant over
keep going Mrs rapino Ms rapino playing
the way that we did and you know having
a ton of Joy on the ball
um I mean this is like a sick joke
for me personally I'm just like this is
dark comedy I missed a penalty
um this is the
the balance to the beautiful side of the
game I think it can be cruel and
um just not our day but
yeah I I still just feel
really grateful and joyful and you know
I know it's the end and that's sad but
um
you know to know that this is really the
only time I've been in in one of these
um this early
um you know says so much about how much
how much success I've been able to have
and
um
just how much I've loved playing for
this team and playing for this country
and
yeah it's been an honor there he goes
then she cracks I'm really proud we did
great I'm awesome I'm the greatest ever
I'm so but I blew it it's so dark why
did I blow it I know you did you did
it's the first step is
first step in grieving is is
acknowledging reality okay right now
text Knowles to 98 98 98 we are now days
away from the Durban Accords
German Accords could be the greatest
threat to us Dollar's Global dominance
in the past 80 years why should you care
since the turn of the century the
world's dollar supply grew 344 percent
each Dollar's purchasing power has
declined 44 leaders around the world are
questioning the value of owning an asset
with Unlimited Supply and a steadily
declining value on August 22nd brics
Nations Brazil Russia India China and
South Africa are expected to announce
the launch of a new international super
currency fully backed by gold or other
Commodities this is part of their
long-term plan to supplant the US dollar
and this is the Cornerstone of the
Global Financial system which could lead
to dire consequences such as higher
prices on Global Imports and Rising loan
rates because the world is simply less
willing to finance mortgages and
infrastructure projects in the U.S you
can protect your IRA or 401K from The
Fallout by diversifying with gold from
Birch gold historically gold has been a
safe haven in times of high uncertainty
which is right now how much more time
does the Dollar have protect your
savings today virtual as an A plus
rating with the Better Business Bureau
of thousands of happy customers text
Knowles to 98 98 98 get your free info
kit on gold it'll be nice to have some
gold to depend upon again as things
collapse text Knowles KW Valley esta 98
98 98 right now go to prageru.com club5
our country might be headed in the wrong
direction but regular U videos could
help save the future of America prageru
makes educational pro-american content
that has been changing people's minds
for over a decade their impact is
pivotal in these times our friends at
Prager you are reaching millions of
people with their educational videos
they have a long way to go you can help
Prager you reach thousands more people
by joining Club five for just five bucks
or more per month go to prageru.com Club
five now to join your gift will ensure
that prageru has the support it needs to
be here for the Long Haul what are you
waiting for join a movement with
thousands of fellow Patriots in the
fight to save America you'll receive a
free pragery bumper sticker plus an
e-book of scripts from prageru's five
minute videos when you join Club 5 today
that is prageru.com Club five c l u b
number five today there's all sorts of
great content at prageru I've been in a
ton of five minute videos obviously I
host the book club over at prageru this
there's really great educational content
for everybody prageru.com Club five
today
why am I so happy that this lady lost
isn't that unpatriotic of me because
it's the U.S women's soccer team isn't
that unpatriotic
well it would be
except the team is very unpatriotic I
know that's a paradox but a paradox is
not just uh an incoherence or a
contradiction it's an apparent
contradiction that can reveal a deeper
truth when you work it out and and when
you work it out here you see
that
the team that is supposed to represent
the United States
consistently undermines the United
States protests the national anthem The
Star Spangled Banner the symbol of the
whole country
is actively anti-patriotic
and so it is
you cannot say that patriotism requires
us to applaud
the people who are deeply unpatriotic
you that would undermine it it reminds
me of a line from Chesterton
Chesterton said there is a thought that
stops thought
and that is the only thought that ought
to be stopped
there is there is a patriotism that
undermines patriotism and that kind of
pseudo-patriotism really ought to be
stopped as far as I'm concerned the U.S
women's soccer team could just be
abolished
cancel it I don't know maybe there were
some patriotic people on the team it's
too bad that the loudest mouth on the
team Megan rapino has so consistently
attacked our country but just abolish it
what is the point of the US Women's
Soccer Team it's not to kick a ball
around it's not to make Megan rapino
feel good it's to represent the United
States to bring glory to our country
that's the point of the team
so if they're if they're actively
undermining that then they have no
purpose and if the salt loses its Savor
then it's good for nothing and ought to
be trodden underfoot okay maybe now that
this lady is gone and can go off into
the sunset maybe the team will remember
what their job is and they can salute
the flag and stop being so deeply
unpatriotic but until then get rid of it
I mean there's a big big political
problem because you've got huge swaths
of America
and hate the country
and then hate traditional Notions of
patriotism and inasmuch as they love the
country they love the country because
they say the country stands for I don't
know
LGBT rights that's that's the deepest
meaning of America who people who really
believe that the rainbow flag is our
national standard or ought to be who
would be much more likely to salute the
rainbow flag than to salute the American
flag then you got the other more than
half of the country that still believes
in the red white and blue and doesn't
believe in all the craziness that rupino
and the libs do but that's a big problem
because if you don't have
shared
beliefs if you don't have shared sacred
objects if you don't have shared
language if you don't have shared
Behavior if you don't have any shared
culture then you don't have a country
doesn't matter which
team is representing your country you
don't have one to be represented in the
first place boy what a great clip that
was now make sure that you ring that
Bell subscribe to the Michael Knowles
YouTube channel see you next time